[Musique]
le canal de panama est à sec ou presque
un problème de taille pour le commerce
maritime mondial en raison des
changements climatiques la région encore
souffert depuis un an d'un grand déficit
de précipitations il manque au minimum 1
milliard 400 millions de mètres cube
d'eau pour fonctionner normalement
c'est l'équivalent de 375000 fils aîné
olympique d'administration du canal de
panama va donc investir 2 milliards de
dollars pour un projet
d'approvisionnement en eau parmi les
solutions suggérées il ya le pompage
d'eau souterraine la construction de
barrages ou l'approvisionnement par
station d'épuration entre temps on doit
réduire le tonnage des bateaux ce qui
ralentit le trafic
il ya 450 millions de tonnes de
marchandises qui sont passés par le
canal de panama l'an dernier ces trois
et demi pour cent du commerce mondial
[Musique]